- just a review here of the sohcahtoa
acronym ok so sine is the opposite over
hypotenuse cosine is adjacent over
hypotenuse tangents opposite of or
adjacent but look what happens here with
these triangles on the unit circle if
the radius is 1 ok the hypotenuse is 1
and say this is 1/2 and this is square
root 3 over 2 if you're finding the sine
of this angle that's opposite over
hypotenuse but when you divide by 1 you
just get 1/2 so if you could think of
this as the y-value and this is the
x-value cosine is adjacent over
hypotenuse so that's x over 1 sine is
opposite over hypotenuse that's why over
1 and tangent is opposite over adjacent
which is y over X so on the unit circle
we say is that cosine is the
x-coordinate sine is the y-coordinate
and the tangent is the Y over X now if
you want to take it one step further the
secant is 1 over X so if you're over
here on the unit circle let's say right
here the secant would be 2 2 over 1 you
just take the reciprocal the cosecant of
theta is 1 over Y or the reciprocal of
the y-coordinate and the cotangent
instead of being Y over X it's going to
be x over Y so what what it does is it
makes it easier to find these common
trig ratios for common angles that we
use a lot 30 45 60 90 and multiples
thereof by just realizing that cosines x
sines Y and tangent so Y over X for
these points here on the unit circle so
we're going to look at some examples but
before we get into that I want to show
you a little bit about the symmetry here
involved in this unit circle so you can
see like the 30-degree angle here okay
30 degrees is PI over 6 and radians but
what I want to show you is
that if you take this triangle and you
reflected over the y-axis what you end
up getting is a triangle that's exactly
congruent to this triangle okay so these
are exactly the same so if you notice
these coordinates are exactly the same
the only difference is that x-coordinate
is negative because you're going to the
left the y-coordinates positive because
you're going up so in the second
quadrant X is negative and Y is positive
if you take this triangle you're
reflected over the x-axis again these
three triangles are congruent and you'll
notice that the coordinate is the exact
same except for the sines are both
negative because you're going left and
down and it's the same thing over here
in the fourth quadrant this 30-degree
angle has the same coordinates as this
30-degree angle but the Y is negative
because you're going right positive down
negative and it's the same for the 45
the 60 you can reflect it over the x
axis the y axis and find all these other
points on the unit circle so what most
students do is they start off with
memorizing the 30 the 45 and the
60-degree coordinates and then they can
find the other ones from there but what
you'll find is eventually you're going
to memorize just the entire unit circle
you'll just be able to visualize it
you'll say oh yeah I see over here right
in my mind you know this is this
coordinate sine is 1/2 you'll just start
to memorize it from doing it so often
okay the next thing I want to talk about
is the Radian units so we're used to
learning degrees first so we're most
comfortable with that but in terms of
radians let me see if I can show you a
little bit about how to break down the
unit circle in terms of radians and so
we know from a previous video that 180
degrees is the same as pi radians so if
you're over here at PI okay that's a
hundred and eighty degrees if you divide
that up into six slices see one two
three four five six each one of these is
going to be one sixth of pi
to six of pi3 sixth of Pi for 6th of Pi
5/6 of Pi and it keeps going 7 8 9 10 11
and 12 okay and if you reduce these
you're gonna get almost all the points
here on the circle so the ones here like
this is PI over 3 if you reduce it to PI
over 3 and so on now if you take the
circle and you look at pi radians pi is
halfway around that's 180 degrees and if
you divide it up into fourths 1/4 2/4
3/4 4/4 this is multiples of PI over 4
so 1 PI over 4 to PI over 4 3 PI over 4
4 PI over 4 5 PI over 4 6 PI over 4 7 PI
over 4 and 8 PI over 4 so this is a way
to find some of these common points on
the unit circle by thinking about it as
a fraction of pi whether it's 1/4 of pi
dividing the half the circle up into
fourths or dividing half the circle up
into sixths or you could even divide
half the circle up into thirds to find
your multiples of PI over 3 the other
thing I want to mention to you is that
in terms of switching back and forth
between radians and degrees
whenever you see PI over 6 you can think
of this as being the 30-degree the quote
30 degree family PI over 4 is the 45
degree family and PI over 3 the 60
degree family and if you forget you can
always put 180 in place of Pi wherever
you see PI so 180 divided by 3 yes
that's 60 or 180 / - yes that's 90 but
if you just remember that these are the
30 degree 45 60 degree families if
somebody says what's 7 PI over 6
and you haven't memorized that one it's
no problem you just look at okay here's
PI over six I know that's the 30 degree
family 7 times 30 ok 7 times 3 is 21 add
to 0 that's 210 degrees you can switch
quickly switch back here's another
example 5 PI over 4 if you know that the
PI over 4 is in the 45 degree family 5
times 45 is 225 so you can quickly do
that calculation until you memorize them
and like I said there's not that many so
as you do this just try to make a
conscious effort to just memorize where
the points located and what it is in
radians degrees and the coordinates but
now what we're going to get into is
finding some of the trig ratios of some
common points on the circle here common
angles so let's do a few examples
together so say you want to find out
what's the sine cosine of 11 PI over 6
okay this is what I would do and this is
what I did when I first started learning
is I would draw the circle just a little
off on the margin of my page and I would
say okay let me see 11 PI over 6 okay I
knew that that was right over there
or if I didn't I could say PI over 6 is
the 30-degree family 11 times 30 is 330
so I know where 330 is it's just 30
degrees shy of 360 one revolution I
memorized the 30 degree 60 degree and 45
degree coordinates on the unit circle so
I knew this is square root 3 over 2 1/2
I also knew that I'm going right that's
positive and I'm going down that's
negative just like you did in the
rectangular coordinate system rights
positive less negative
oops positive and downs negative so I
knew the sine is the y-coordinate so I
knew that it was 1/2 and a negative 1/2
because it's negative here in the fourth
quadrant let's do another example see
you want to find out the cosine of let's
just say it's 5 PI over 4
okay now you can see the unit circle
over here so you can reference that but
if you want to try to memorize it this
is the process that you could go through
PI over four is a 45-degree angle okay
so if you think about that unit circle
one PI over four to PI over 4 3 PI over
4 4 PI over 4 5 PI over 4
I know PI over 4 is a 45 degree angle so
I know these coordinates here are root 2
over 2 root 2 over 2 they're both
negative because I'm in the third
quadrant I'm going to left and down and
the cosine I know is the x-coordinate on
the unit circle signs the white and it's
y over X cosine X so my answer is
negative square root 2 over 2 now a note
on whether your trig ratios are positive
or negative some teachers will teach
this little acronym all students take
calculus so it goes like this 1 2 3 4
all students take calculus so what this
means is that they're all positive in
the first quadrant sine cosine and
tangent are all positive sine is
positive here but the cosine and tangent
are negative tangents positive here but
the sine and cosine are negative and the
cosine is positive here but the sine and
the tangent are negative so if you
prefer that acronym you can go that
route I just like to think about you
know the coordinates if it's positive
you know or if it's negative and cosines
the X signs of Y changes Y over X but
this might help you initially as well
let's do a few more examples and I think
you'll start getting the hang of this I
know it's a big topic the unit circle
but you want to just dive into it and
start start memorizing it there's only
you know a handful of coordinates on
here so eventually you will just
memorize all the Radian measures as well
as the coordinates so let's say you
wanted to find out now the tangent of
let's just say it's 2 PI over 3 okay we
have this to reference here but say you
didn't what you could do is you could
say hmm PI over 3 that's the 60-degree
phase
Emily - times 60 is 120 where is 120
degrees well you start here it's
positive you go that direction if it's
negative you go that direction we know
that so this is 90 plus 30 more I drop a
perpendicular to the x-axis and this
reference angle is a 60 degree reference
angle so that means that I know the
coordinates at this point it's a 60
degree this is going to be 1/2 + square
root 3 over 2 this is going to be
negative because we're going left
ok that's negative up that's positive
tangent I know is the Y over the X okay
so tangent is y over X so that's going
to be this coordinate divided by that
coordinate so square root 3 over 2
divided by negative 1/2
and you can see if you multiply by 2
over 2 these twos are going to cancel
you get square root 3 over negative 1
which is negative square root of 3 so
the tangent of 2 PI over 3 is negative
square root of 3 another technique that
you can use ok with the 30 and 60 degree
angles is that see over here this 60
degree triangle see how this leg is the
shorter than this leg we know the
hypotenuse is 1 but this short leg is
going to be the 1/2 side the longer leg
is going to be the square root 3 over 2
side 1/2 is 0.5 square root 3 over 2 is
about 0.87 0.87 of course is bigger than
0.5 we know that square root 3 over 2 is
larger than 1/2 so if you draw your
triangle and your angles to scale you
don't just stop you know throw it up
there you're going to be able to tell
okay X is the short leg y is the long
leg in this example and I'll show you
another example and how to use this
technique so let's say we want to find
let's do the cosine okay of how about
let's do maybe five PI over three
okay cosine of 5 PI over 3 so say we
didn't have the unit circle to reference
again what we could do is we could say
PI over 3 is in the 63 family 5 times 60
is 300 so let's see we're 300 is on this
unit circle it's going to be 90 180 270
30 more okay we drop a perpendicular to
the x-axis you always want to go to the
X never to the Y always to the x-axis
and you look at that angle in between
the x axis and the terminal ray okay
and that's your reference angle so
that's a 60-degree angle now you can see
I've drawn it pretty well to scale this
is the short leg so I know that's 1/2
that's the longer leg I know that square
root 3 over 2 I know this is negative
cuz I'm going down I know this is
positive because I'm going to the right
cosine I know is the X so it's a
positive 1/2 now that seemed like a long
process but as you do that a number of
times you'll be able to visualize
exactly where that is and you'll know
what those values are so again now it's
a 45 degree angle 45 you're going to be
able to see this is exactly isosceles
this leg and this leg are exactly the
same so you're gonna know that these are
congruent we know that's the root 2 over
2 root 2 over 2 point here for the
45-degree angle so this has been a
little bit about the unit circle again
take some time to memorize it and to
practice and work with it if you have to
draw the circle off to the side that's a
good way to start initially and then
eventually like I said you'll you'll
memorize it so I'll see you in the next
video